Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wie hast du die Woche verbracht?
Doch recht viel vor den Nachrichten. Du auch?
Bisschen.
Ja schon.
Ich bin jetzt nicht wach geblieben bis 2 Uhr nachts, aber ja.
Ich auch nicht. Das zeichnete sich ja dann doch am späten Abend ab, dass irgendwie miteinander geredet wird. Ich bin schockiert darüber, dass man von der Bundesregierung eigentlich nichts dazu gehört hat, dass Donald Trump dort verkündet, eine Zivilisation auszurotten. Und der einzige höherrangige Politiker, der aber ein Politiker AD ist, der sich dazu kritisch äußert, ist Peter Altmaier, der quasi aus dem Ruhestand heraus bei Twitter mal schreibt, dass das so nicht geht.
Bei Twitter?
Und sonst gibt es dazu eigentlich gar nichts. Es ist so skandalös, und dass überhaupt die Situation entstehen konnte, dass man also nicht vorher von Seiten der EU und von Seiten vor allem der Bundesrepublik sich vehement gegen Trumps Kurs und auch gegen Netanyaus Kurs gestellt hat. Und Netanyau ja immer noch gewähren lässt, der jetzt ja gerade dabei ist, den Libanon Stück für Stück dem Erdboden gleich zu machen, ist für mich skandalös. Also ich finde da kaum Worte für.
Also ich finde auch, ich war jetzt noch nie im Iran, will aber mal hin. Denn bei meinem Lieblings-Afghanen hier in Banusviertel hängen Wandteppiche, an denen die persischen Städten, ich weiß, ich hab keine Ahnung, von damals wahrscheinlich gab es noch keinen Unterschied zwischen Afghanistan und Iran oder so. Deshalb da, oder übersetzt man diesen Text mit seiner Translator-App und ist ja, also ist ja reingestrickt, so ne, wird trotzdem erkannt, so. Also Buchstaben, von denen man denkt, ist das, gehört das schon zum Gemälde oder ist das inhaltlicher Text? Und dann steht da so 4000 Jahre alt. Und das will man ja eigentlich mal sehen. Und wenn dann so eine Zivilisationszerstörung angekündigt wird, ist eigentlich ein angekündigter Zivilisationsbruch. Ja. So.
Ja.
Und wir wissen ja im deutschen Strafrecht, Mord, Mordversuche ist im Grunde das selbe. Ich war, weil du jetzt so sagst, es zeichnet sich ja ab, das und so. Man weiß ja immer nicht so genau, was im Fahrwasser der Geschichte so passiert. Es hätte ja auch sein können, dass man morgens aufwacht und dann heißt es, ja, die Chinesen sind jetzt auf Taiwan gelandet.
Weit und breit kein amerikanisches Schiff, nicht mal Satelliten in der Nähe, die das beobachten oder so. Alle gebunden bei so einem Manöver. Und von daher würde ich das jetzt im Sinne von Puh nochmal gut gegangen, nicht geschehen, nicht durchgehen lassen.
Nein, das sowieso nicht.
Sondern es gibt große Erklärungsbedarfe, finde ich, von unserer Regierung. Anscheinend saßen einfach alle nur zu Hause und haben so gehofft, dass nichts passiert. Ja. Und es ist ja nicht nichts passiert. Das Drehbuch für Beirut kennen wir aus Raffa. Ja. Also jedes Haus muss zerstört werden. Man sieht ja auf Instagram diese Videos, wie einfach ganze Dörfer gleichzeitig gesprengt werden. Wo man sich fast denkt, machen die sich ein Spaß daraus. Also wird das erst verkabelt, wie bei so einem Sprengunternehmer, der hier so ganz vorsichtig ein Haus springt. Also es ist alles sehr betrüblich, aber...
Zugleich wurde in Israel die Todesstrafe für Palästinense eingeführt.
Ja, und mit Champagner begossen.
Da gibt es auch ein Wort für, ich glaube, das heißt Apartheid, das dann fallen könnte.
Ja.
Es ist so dramatisch und es wird von Seiten der EU, also jetzt Spanien mal ausgenommen, viel zu wenig widersprochen. Und von Deutschland ist ja gar nichts mehr zu erwarten. Also alle gehen auf Tauchstation. Hier ist man ja beschäftigt, dass man nicht mal die eigenen Gesetze kennt, die man verabschiedet. Da muss dann jemand aus der Frankfurter Rundschau mal nachsehen, was das eigentlich bedeutet. Das ist doch alles absurd.
Müssen wir jetzt wirklich alle Gesetze selber durch unsere eigene KI lesen lassen, weil es niemand mehr tut. Also das ist ja wirklich Redaktionsschluss, sonderes Gleich. Also wir reden über diese kleine Floskel bei der, oder Klausel, bei der im Nachhinein noch Rätselraten war, ob sie jetzt überhaupt gilt oder nicht. Ja, dass wir beide uns jetzt melden müssten, falls wir, keine Ahnung, ins Ausland gehen.
Drei Monate ins Ausland gehen, dass man sich dann meldet, dass man sich beim Karrierecenter oder wo auch immer bei der Bundeswehr abmeldet, wenn man männlich ist und im Alter von 18 bis 45 Jahren. Das ist so skandalös, dass ein Redakteur der Frankfurter Rundschau das mal nachliest und dann mal seine Konsequenzen daraus sieht und man dann ihm erst einmal bei der Bundeswehr gar nichts dazu sagen kann. Das Verteidigungsministerium duckt sich, stellt sich tot, erst einmal, bis dann irgendwann Boris Pistorius sich auch nicht so recht erklären kann. Und ich frage mich auch, haben wir eigentlich im Parlament noch eine Opposition sitzen, die diese Gesetze liest? Also was macht eigentlich die Linkspartei außer TikTok-Tänze? Muss ich jetzt sie auch mal fragen, weil die auch immer nur so handzahm irgendwas gegen Aufrüstung und so weiter, aber auch wir brauchen Sicherheit. Dann muss man sich auch mal mit den Maßnahmen, die jetzt da gemacht werden, auseinandersetzen, damit man zum Beispiel auch seine eigenen Leute mobilisieren kann dagegen. Wenn man dann aber selbst davon überrascht ist und dann einfach nur beklagt, was wirklich von Teilen der Linkspartei kam, von den Grünen natürlich auch, aber da erwarten wir nichts mehr, dass das Gesetz sei schlecht gebaut. Nein, das hat nichts mit schlecht gebaut zu tun. Das heißt hier, dass Männer plötzlich an die Kandare genommen werden sollen und sich dem zu fügen haben, weil das dem Staatsinteresse dient. Und ich hab mich auch sehr aufgeregt, dass dabei so Leute, die über Ole und alle, die gegen Wehrpflicht sind, hergefallen sind, wie zum Beispiel Florian Schröder, plötzlich sich darüber lustig machen und das alles ganz skandalös finden, dass es jetzt dieses Gesetz gibt, dass man sich da melden sollte. Nee, das ist die reine Konsequenz dessen, was Ole und die anderen immer ausgeführt haben. Und ich finde es noch skandalöser, dass dann Boris Pistorius sich zu Wort meldet und Folgendes sagt, das wird dann überall zitiert und so getan wie, ja ist er nur halb so wild, also alles in Ordnung. Boris Pistorius sagt, derzeit ändert sich für die Männer nichts, ob 17 oder 45 Jahre oder dazwischen, alle dürfen selbstverständlich verreisen und brauchen derzeit dafür auch keine Genehmigung. Zwei Mal derzeit in einem Satz bedeutet, naja, genau derzeit nicht, aber morgen kann es schon anders sein. Und dass man da nicht entsprechend mobilisiert dagegen, dass das einfach so durchgeht, wo alle sonst immer eine Freiheitsberaubung sehen, wo kleine Stellschrauben verändert werden sollen, finde ich wirklich absurd. Also absurd sage ich heute schon viel zu häufig, aber anders weiß ich es nicht mehr zu beschreiben und finde es ja im höchsten Maße skandalös, dass es nicht skandalisiert wird. Ich finde auch erstaunlich, wo sind eigentlich die großen Demonstrations-Aufrufe, dass vor der amerikanischen Botschaft demonstriert wird oder irgendwas. Wir haben einen Manfred Weber, der bei Lanz sitzt und sagt, dieser Krieg ist im deutschen Interesse, also bezogen auf Iran. Wir haben CSU-Leute bei Lanz sitzen, die sagen, wir müssen jetzt mal abwarten mit diesem Energiegesetz, mit dem Kartellrechtsverschärfungen und so weiter, dann werden wir das mit den Energiepreisen und den Spritpreisen schon in den Griff bekommen. Nichts passiert. Wir haben eine Wirtschaftsministerin Reiche, die eine völlig bescheuerte Regelung eingeführt hat, dass die Tankstellen nur einmal am Tag den Preis erhöhen dürfen. Ja, was machen die natürlich? Sie nehmen erstmal den höchsten Preis, um sicher zu gehen, dass sie auf keinen Fall Verluste machen. Also um 12 Uhr kracht es so richtig rauf. Wem ist damit geholfen? Also man hat jetzt auch noch darüber Gewinne produziert, von denen man aber die ganze Zeit sagt, es gibt sie gar nicht. Es ist nicht mehr zu fassen.
Ja, dann haben wir heute genau die richtige Literatur dazu. Zum einen das Absurde ist jetzt ein Grundbegriff im politischen Denken. Die Kritik an die Politiker schön und gut, aber in der Demokratie wurde der Kunde zum König erklärt und er hat die Rolle nie ganz angenommen. Das wird uns heute auch erklärt. Und wir kriegen von Adrian Daub zum Thema Vibe und Vibe Shift Aufklärung, die ich hoch interessant finde. Lass mich das aber noch mal historisch zusammenbinden, denn es war Ostern, ich war auf Reisen. Meine Herkunft ist ja bekannt, ich komme aus Jena. Dort fand eine sehr kräftezehrende und blutrünstige Schlacht statt. 1806, Jena-Auerstedt, Napoleon überrascht die Preußen mit der Idee, wir kommen aus allen Himmelsrichtungen. Die Preußen stehen nur gerade da wie befohlen. Dann kommt Napoleon und Napoleon selbst ist überrascht, dass sein einer Kommandant noch vom Norden auskommen kann. Und es gibt eine herbe Niederlage. Die Franzosen rennen nach Berlin, laufen durchs Brandenburger Tor, bauen dann später sogar den Versailler Saal irgendwie nach Anmutung, Brandenburger Tor, wie auch immer. Und dann, wie gesagt, ich war auf Reisen, ich war im Saarland das erste Mal.
Wie du warst das erste Mal in diesem Bundesland.
Ja, es ist so klein, es führt keinen Weg. Man muss schon richtig hinfahren, damit man es nicht verpasst. Jedenfalls war ich im Saarland und dort gibt es einen Ort, der heißt nicht Auerstedt, sondern es ist der rote Berg von, jetzt muss ich hier nachschauen, wie das heißt, Schielen, warte einen Moment, Spicher, der Spicher, Spicher. Auch dort eine Schlacht, 1870, also 64 Jahre nach Auerstedt. Diesmal herbe Niederlage für die Franzosen. Wie? Sie wurden überrascht, wie sie damals überrascht haben. Angriffe aus allen Himmelsrichtungen. Ich habe Claude gebeten, das zu visualisieren. Wir können uns das kurz angucken. Ich bin diesen Berg hoch auf ein Restaurant gegangen und dachte, wow, das ist echt steil. Und dann oben ein großes gegossenes Betonkreuz, zwölf Meter hoch oder so. Das daran erinnert, dass damals gegen die Franzosen auf diesen Berg gerannt wurde und Bismarck dann den großen Sieg verkünden konnte. Ein Jahr später. Der Stuhl, auf dem man die Unterschrift setzte, steht ja hier bei uns im historischen Museum. Und ich möchte gern vorlesen, aus einer Info-Tafel, die dort rumstand, folgendes. Am 18. Januar 1871 wird Wilhelm I im glanzvollen Spiegelsaal des Schlosses von Versailles, der also auch gebaut wurde als Erinnerung, dass die Franzosen mal erfolgreich in Berlin gelandet sind, zum Kaiser ernannt. Der Kanzler hatte seinen Traum verwirklicht, Deutschland zu einen, Frankreich zu demütigen und sich für die Schlacht von Jena 1806 zu rächen. Ich kriege also im Saarland eine Aufklärung darüber, was 400 Kilometer weit weg, heute eh schon Jahrhunderte her, damals auch schon drei Generationen her passierte. Und ich denke mir so, wir beobachten diese Kriege gerade unter, ja mal gucken, was morgen ist. So. Und dann übermorgen ist schon, ah nee, ist jetzt doch wieder Epstins Fall, Dominant oder was auch immer so, ja. Nur wenn man so eine ganze Stadt wie Rafah oder jetzt Beirut und der ganze Kram, Androhung eines, wie nennt man das denn jetzt, Zivilisationsmord des iranischen Volkes und so, ja. Glaubt man denn jetzt ernsthaft, das wird alles morgen vergessen, also bei den Beteiligten dort, es gibt ja auch Betroffene so.
Ja. Und nicht wenige.
Das ist irgendwie eine sehr schräge Lage dafür, dass wir in Europa überall, also im Saarland, man stolpert quasi von einem Kriegerdenkmal über das nächste.
Ja.
Man guckt dann immer, um was geht es hier? 1871, 1914, 1918, 1939, 1945, also es geht ja eine Reihe um, dass wir das gerade so in Friedenszeiten durch den deutsch-französischen Garten da gehen und sagen, da stehen die Rosen, da kümmern sich übrigens Franzosen und Deutsche im gleichen Maße drum und wie auch immer, also kleinste Freundschaftsgesen, die da aber ganz ernst genommen werden. Und dann höre ich im Radio auf der Rückfahrt, dass Anke Rehlinger findet, Anke Rehlinger ist die mit mehr als 50 Prozent regierende saarländische Ministerpräsidentin.
SPD.
SPD, die also gefragt wird, ja sie können es ja offenbar, wollen sie nicht in Berlin und so. Und sie sagt, ja ein bisschen mithelfen geht schon, aber ich kann nicht SPD-Chefin werden, weil Berlin ist zu weit weg. Und ich denke mir, das ist doch das einzige Kriterium, das wir gerade brauchen.
Weit weg von Berlin.
Weit weg von Berlin, um die SPD zu führen.
Ich würde sogar vorschlagen, dass...
Dass Willy Brandhaus in Saarbrücken aufzukommen.
Ja ganz richtig. Ich würde vorschlagen, Anke Rehlinger darf in Saarbrücken bleiben, regiert von dort aus die Bundes-SPD. Und wer von Berlin kommen will, muss einen Antrag stellen bei Boris Pistorius.
Der Auftrag, die SPD zu retten, wird nicht erlöscht, wenn man zu Fuß in Berlin aufkreuzt. Wenn man denkt, die müssen jetzt alle nach Saarbrücken. Das wäre meine Idee. In so einem Ort, wo man noch so richtig, also man sieht von überall Kriegerdenkmäler. Das sind da nicht einfach Stolpersteine, wo man so ach ja okay und so, sondern die stehen da einfach mannshoch, das sind die Kleinen, und turmhoch im ganzen Saarland verteilt. Vielleicht ist das einfach der richtige Mindset, um jetzt mal hier Oppositionen der Regierung zu machen. Aber nur eine weitere Empfehlung aus der Podcastlandschaft.
Wir haben heute zwei Bücher, die unglaublich gut zu diesem Thema passen. Wir sprechen über Adrian Daupp, was das Welli Herrschen nennt. Wir haben von ihm schon besprochen, was das Welli Denken nennt. Jetzt geht es also darum, dass sie Herrschen nach Macht ja gar nicht streben, sondern nach Dominanz vor allem. Und da muss man unterscheiden, was das eigentlich meint. Du hast schon gesagt, Adrian Dau beschreibt den Vibe-Shift, der stattgefunden hat. Er beschreibt diese männliche Herrschaft.
Das ist schon ganz wichtig hier schon zu sagen. Er definiert überhaupt erst mal Vibe. Und damit die Unterscheidung zwischen, und das finde ich auch in unserem Podcast ganz wichtig, einem intuitiven und einem institutionellen Denkrahmen. Denn das kann sehr weit auseinanderfallen. Man hört ein halbes Jahr lang, jetzt muss irgendwo hin, irgendwas muss geliefert werden, Panzer, Leoparden, was auch immer. Und man sieht alle Institutionen im Gleichschritt in diese Richtung laufen. Und dann macht man eine Demoskopie und stellt fest, zwei Drittel der Deutschen finden das gar nicht. Das ist, also Vibe-Shift auch wichtig, aber Vibe-Diskrepanz. Ja, dass das so in der Definition drinsteckt, finde ich, das werden wir nachher herausstellen.
Bis hin zu exakten Analysen, einzelner Tweets von Elon Musk, die man lange Zeit abgetan hat als, naja, ist das so ein bisschen verrückt wie jedes Genie, aber das da doch viel mehr dahinter steckt. Dann auch, fragen wir uns ja häufig, wenn wir diese Leute sehen, Peter Thiel, Jeff Bezos, wenn man sich ihre Lebensläufe ansieht, ihre Beziehungen ansieht, wie passt das eigentlich alles zusammen? Also wie kann man ganz recht sein und dann zugleich aber wieder dort progressiv, wie kann das eigentlich zusammengehören, dass man einwandert in die USA und dann trotzdem eigentlich alle noch mal von rechts überholt? Wie ist es möglich, dass man von Demokratisierung spricht und da eigentlich eine Diktatur am liebsten errichten würde? Wie passt das alles zusammen? Und Afrikan Daupp sagt, naja, es passt eigentlich alles ziemlich gut zusammen. Unsere Kategorien, unsere alten, die greifen nicht mehr. Und deswegen passt da etwas nicht mehr. Das können wir also lernen, welche neuen Kategorien es da gibt. Peter Sloterdijk schreibt ein Buch, das heißt Der Fürst und seine Erben über große Männer im Zeitalter der gewöhnlichen Leute. Das Interessante ist, dass hier als Klappentext noch etwas draufsteht, was man, glaube ich, wenn man das Buch jetzt gerade drucken würde, nicht mehr drauf schreiben würde, wie es steht. Als Madman ohne Plan für den nächsten Tag ist Trump fürs erste weit weniger gefährlich als sein Gegenspieler im Kreml. Würden wir jetzt nach den vergangenen Tagen nicht mehr so sehen. Das hat aber den Buch, hat aber jetzt den Buchinhalt nicht geschwächt, sondern es hat eine Aktualität, die noch zugenommen hat.
Ja, also ich finde schon, dass die Rückseite schon noch wichtig ist und zwar, dass das im Buch auch gut begründet wird, denn das, was wir gerade in Amerika sehen, ist total wirkmächtig, obwohl der Typ so dumm ist. Und jetzt stelle dir mal vor, da säße ein Putin.
Ja, nur habe ich nicht den Eindruck, dass Trump besonders rational vorgeht, während ich ja Putin bei aller Brutalität immer noch eine Rationalität unterstelle. So und deswegen sehe ich jetzt gerade bei einem Trump wirklich die Gefahr, dass der sagt, die Verhandlungen mit dem Iran haben nichts gebracht, die Straße von Hormuz ist nicht auf, wir drücken jetzt auf den roten Knopf. Da sehe ich jetzt bei Trump gerade akut eine größere Gefahr.
Wir lesen heute einen weiteren Text aus der New York Times. Ich lese heute nur Texte, die viel besprochen sind, also wo das so mitläuft, das viel zu besprochen ist. Nämlich diese Aufarbeitung von Maggie Haberman und Swann, wie heißt der? Jeremy Swann? Jonathan Swann. Äh, die beiden planen ein Buch. Und die Anbahnung von dem, was wir jetzt gesehen haben oder überhaupt des Iran-Kriegs wird da auch schon besprochen. Und äh, es lauert doch nirgendwo ein Putin in dem Sinne, weil du jetzt die Rationalität, also diese Dummheit führt dann halt auch zu nichts. Also Klarheiten, die jetzt, die könnten jetzt Atomwaffen einsetzen und so, allein weil sie es so potenziell können. Aber bislang schützt uns doch die Dummheit mehr davor als was?
Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher. Also nach dieser Woche bin ich mir da nicht mehr sicher. Vor einer Woche, vor zwei Wochen vielleicht. Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, was aber doch interessant ist bei Sotadeik, dass er in diesem Buch Machiavelli noch einmal aufschlägt und schaut, welche Parallelen gibt es eigentlich zu unserer Gegenwart. Und er hat viele anzubieten. Darüber sprechen wir. Was wirst du also noch mitbringen? Du hast schon einen Text jetzt genannt.
Swan und Habermann Haberman lesen, how Trump took the US to war with Iran. Dann Timothy Snyder, der publiziert auf eigene Faust bei Substack, aber der wohl jetzt, Stand 4. April, dann meist gelesene Text dort. Da zumindest, man sieht ja so, wie viele Kommentare und wie die das nennen, Restacks oder was auch immer. The Next Coup Attempt and How to Stop It. Er geht in 5 Punkten durch, wie die Midterms. Also vom Iran-Krieg bis zu den Midterms macht er die Planung. Und dann ein Text einfach nur wegen der Pointe, die wirklich sehr überraschend, überzeugend ist, aber grundsätzlich uns alle betrifft, sage ich mal. Anna Holms hat in The Atlantic über, warum sie sich dagegen sträubt, immer mit dem Trend zu gehen, beim Fernsehserien schauen. The people who shun super popular pop culture. Also shun im Sinne von für sich. Umso größer die Empfehlung, umso mehr lehnen sie es ab. Dann gucken sie es lieber heimlich oder wie auch immer, aber geben es nicht zu. Klar, man kann das intuitiv durchgehen. Was ist das für ein komisches Phänomen? Reaktanz spielt natürlich eine große Rolle. Aber sie hat am Ende eine ganz interessante Pointe, die auch noch mal einen Redaktionsschluss anschließt und so.
Ich habe ein Buch, das gerade heiß diskutiert wird dabei, von Jörg Barbarowski, Am Volk vorbei zur Krise der liberalen Demokratie. Auf dieses Buch bin ich noch mal besonders aufmerksam geworden, weil es in der Zeit von Christian Straß eine lange Rezension gab, in der die ganze Zeit betont wurde, wie gefährlich das ist und dass der Autor doch da sehr rechte Ansichten hat. Und da ich dachte, dass es doch Zeit ist, mehr gefährliche Bücher zu lesen, wollte ich unbedingt zugreifen. Das habe ich dann gemacht und war sehr überrascht. Denn ich könnte mir jetzt auch gleich die Mühe machen, um herauszuarbeiten, dass Jörg Barbarowski nicht links ist. Das kann ich dann an Äußerungen zur Migrationspolitik zeigen oder an irgendeinem links-liberalen Bashing, das vielleicht da und dort über die Stränge schlägt. Manchmal aber würde ich auch sagen, nicht? Jedenfalls könnte ich das tun. Das wäre so eine Fleißarbeit, die ziemlich geistlos ist. Stattdessen würde ich eigentlich die, genau, die Clot machen kann. Und viel geistreicher ist eigentlich das, was Barbarowski selbst tut und das dann auch selbst weiterdenken, wenn man sein Buch gelesen hat. Nämlich, er bedankt sich anfangs bei verschiedenen Autoren, dass er als Historiker überhaupt so ein Buch schreiben kann. Da sind unter anderem genannt Philipp Manow. Da sind aber also jemand, der jetzt auch gerade sehr heiß diskutiert wird, weil er sagt, naja, Demokratie und liberale Demokratie sind nicht identisch. Wir hatten dieses Buch unter Beobachtung oder ich hatte es hier mal vorgestellt. Er bedankt sich aber auch bei Leuten wie Wendy Brown und Chantal Mouffe, also linken Denkern. Und er bezieht sich durchgehend in diesem Buch auf Karl Schmitt, aber auch auf viele sehr linke, ich würde sagen, bis hin zu kommunistischen, französischen Theoretikern und sagt, naja, diese Demokratie und wie sie uns da die ganze Zeit beschrieben wird, ist eine große Ideologie. Das muss man erst mal erkennen. Man muss schon sich darüber im Klaren sein, wie sind die Herrschaftsverhältnisse. Und das bedeutet, dass man jetzt hier nicht einfach so eine friedliche Einheit und eine ungespaltene Gesellschaft oder sowas haben kann. Er geht soweit zu sagen, das, was am Populismus stattfindet, ist eine Belebung der Demokratie. Denn Demokratie bedeutete eigentlich immer auch, dass das sogenannte Staatsvolk gegen den Staat agiert. Und wir haben sehr viel Staatstragendes gerade. Wir haben Bücher hier gehabt oder darüber zumindest in Ansätzen geredet, die sagen, wir müssen mehr vertrauen und wir müssen mehr dies und das. Barbarowski geht da einen anderen Weg. Ist ein Autor, der ja da böse analytisch rangeht, aber damit zu einer enormen Klarheit kommt. Das also werde ich vorstellen und werde jetzt meine Kritik von links da gar nicht so groß machen, weil ich sage, das muss man produktiv von links lesen. Alexander Kluge, wir haben darüber gesprochen, ist verstorben. Dann kaufe ich mir ein Buch, das heißt Transkription von Ben Lerner, weil es darum geht, dass da ein junger Mann oder so jung ist er gar nicht 45, möchte ein allerletztes Interview mit seinem Mentor führen, ein Mann, der sich zwischen Kunst und zwischen Literatur, zwischen Wissenschaften und Film bewegt. Dann stellt sich heraus, dieser Mann, der da besucht wird, heißt zwar Thomas, aber porträtiert wird hier Alexander Kluge. Zumindest werden Einsprengse verwendet. Ben Lerner und Kluge waren nämlich miteinander befreundet. Und hier wird Alexander Kluge in Form dieses Thomas verewigt, wenn das dann auch weiter ins Fiktionale gedehnt wird. Alexander Kluge hat auch dieses Buch noch gelesen und hat das auch als eine Geste der Freundschaft gesehen. Ein sehr interessantes Werk. Wir werden uns mit einem Text beschäftigen, der Merkur erschienen ist von Roman Wider, einem Schriftsteller, der sehr auf der pro-ukrainischen Seite ist, der auch sein Dissertationsvorhaben schon früh geändert hat, weil er auf keinen Fall da gewisse russische Autoren mehr drin haben wollte. Er beschreibt das sehr gut. Er rechnet aber jetzt ab mit den Ukraine-Experten, die hier in Deutschland so sind, vor allem Carlo Massalla. Ein hochinteressanter Text. Dann aus Le Monde Diplomatique, Fanny Peugeot über Kongo und den Mineralienabbau und noch Musik aus Russland bzw. von russischen Komponisten im Exil.
Sehr gut. Ich habe eine Frage an die Hörer. Jetzt wo ich wieder physische Bücher kaufe, stapeln sie sich. Und ich möchte gern wissen, was zu lesen ist von mir im nächsten Salon. Zur Auswahl stehen vier Bücher. Zum einen Anna Verena Nosthoff, Kybernetik und Kritik. Ich habe es noch nicht gelesen. Das ist ja für heute fast in Planung, aber das wäre viel zu viel gewesen. Außerdem das knappe Gut Arbeit, was die KI übrig lässt.
Ich bin sehr dafür, dass wir das vielleicht sogar gemeinsam besprechen.
Dann, was ich auf jeden Fall lesen werde und die Frage, wie schnell. Fritz B. Simon, wie Diktaturen funktionieren. Es sind auf dem Cover alle drauf. Das ist ein Buch, das mich sowieso sehr interessiert, weil ja, wir finden alle Putin, Stalin, Trump und so weiter, Gaddafi blöd, aber sie haben ja trotzdem ein Werk vollbracht. Also die, sagen wir mal so, Unterjochung eines Volkes muss ja auch irgendwie handwerklich gelingen. Dem könnte man nachgehen. Und Hartmut Rosa, Situation und Konstellation. Hartmut Rosa, manchmal ein bisschen verlacht von mir nicht, denn ich finde es immer sehr inspirierend im Sinne von, aber ich finde es immer sehr aufrüttelnd. Und ich finde es ja gut, wenn Soziologen die Orthodoxie ein bisschen verlassen und einfach sagen, es gibt schon eine Welt, in der das alles stattfindet und der widme ich mich jetzt auch mal.
Ja, ich habe diese Faszinationen nie so nachvollziehen können, aber gut.
Also wir können ja ein Voting machen im Forum und dann wird eins davon auf jeden Fall. Also wenn du sagst, das Arbeitsbuch...
Wir schauen uns das zumindest mal an.
Okay, gut. Dann würde ich doch vorschlagen. Gut.
Jetzt sagst du noch, wie wir in den Salon kommen, für alle, die den noch nicht abonniert haben.
Man geht auf die Webseite neuezwanziger.de. Dort findet man alles, was zu finden ist zu diesem Podcast, wie auch einen großen goldenen Salon-Button oder direkt unten die drei Pakete zur Auswahl. Kann man anklicken, ist man bei Steady, gibt man seine E-Mail-Adresse und seinen Namen an, fertig ist. Damit hat man Zugang zum gesamten Archiv, allen Kapitelmarken und überhaupt alles, was der Salon zu bieten hat. Falls man schon einen Patreon-Account hat, weil man amerikanischen Creatoren folgt oder wie auch immer, findet man uns da auch. Und wenn man es ganz einfach mag und seine Podcasts eh in der Apple Podcasts App hört, also auch diesen hier, dann taucht ja zu diesem Vorgespräch einfach der ganze Salon in gleichem Feed auf. Nur nicht mit einem Play-Button, sondern mit einem 4-Euro-Button. Und dann kann man den auch anklicken. Das ist dann die Einklick-Lösung. Aber ja, erst mal dann im Apple-Gefängnis.
In irgendeinem Gefängnis ist man ja immer. Also wir freuen uns, wenn ihr uns, unseren Podcast mit einem Salon-Abo unterstützt. Study, Apple oder Patreon, ganz egal. Dort im Archiv findet ihr dann auch unsere Besprechung zu dem vorherigen Buch von Peter Sloterdijk. Da setzt er sich mit Europa auseinander. Und wie gesagt, wir haben schon über, was das Welli-Denken nennt, gesprochen von Adrian Daupp. Das ist jetzt nicht die Fortsetzung, sondern eine andere, ja, Themen-Sicht wird hier eingenommen, eine andere Blickweise noch einmal.
Genau. Jemand hatte uns eine Mail geschrieben mit, man müsste ja im Archiv immer so viel klicken um die Folgen und überhaupt und so. Wenn man wissen will, was wir alles gelesen haben, und zwar jeder einzelne Text seit Mai 2020, die letzten ersten drei muss ich noch nacharbeiten, händisch. Man geht auf neunezwanziger.de/salonoderneunezwanziger.deunddann gibt es oben einen Button oder einen Link mit Lektüre. Da findet man alle aufgelistet, da muss man nicht weiter klicken, sondern da sind alle schon ersichtlich. Und dann gibt es sogar ein Suchfeld, da kann man einfach DAUB eingeben und dann sieht man immer, wenn wir über DAUB gesprochen haben. Oder alle anderen Autoren. Das ist sehr viel einfacher als in den E-Mails, die wir bekommen immer, weil man nicht einfach mal in der Webseite oben die Menüleiste durchgehen kann.
Wir haben eine Webseite, sie ist sehr gut. Ich nutze sie nämlich auch, um wiederzufinden, was wir eigentlich alle schon besprochen haben. neuenzwanziger.de Dann sehen wir uns jetzt gleich im Salon.
Bis gleich.